[موسيقى]
بدايه لازم احنا الناس المتعوده انها تشرب
قهوه بنصحها نصيحه كتير مهمه انه نحاول
نخفف من استهلاك القهوه بالايام القليله
اللي قبل شهر رمضان المبارك راح يساعدنا
كتير في مرحله انه هي تخفف علينا اعراض
وقف استهلاك القهوه خلال النهار فبالتالي
رح يكون الصداع اخف وبنقدر نشتغل طاقه
احسن بالنسبه للافطار جزء كتير مهم من
الافطار لازم يكون مغطى بالسوائل والالياف
الكربوهيدرات والبروتينات لحتى تعطينا
وجبه صحيه متكامله بنفس الوقت ما يؤثر على
الهضم تبعنا وما يعمل عنا عصر هذا كثير من
الناس بتعاني من الامساك فتره رمضان فاحنا
بننصح دائما انه ننتبه على السوائل وكميه
السوائل اللي بنشربها خلال اليوم عاده
طبعا بنفضل انها تكون من خلال شرب المي
اكثر من العصيرات او المشروبات العاليه في
السكر والم
خلينا دائما مركزين عم نشرب مي لو كانت
الكميه مش قادرين نوصلها الكميه اللي احنا
محتاجينها ممكن ناخذ احتياجنا من السوائل
عن طريق الفواكه والشوربات هاي كمان
تعطينا كميه منيحه من الماء
بشكل غير مباشر بدنا كتير ننتبه على موضوع
الامساك انه احنا ما يصير معنا امساك خلال
هاي الفتره بزياده عنصر الالياف اللي هو
جدا مهم خلال شهر رمضان المبارك موجوده
طبعا بالخضار والفواكر فواكه المجففه اللي
ممكن هي تكون بديل صحي جدا للحلويات
الرمضانيه المشهوره
وجبه السحور بتمنى انه ما حدا يهملها هي
وجبه كثير اساسيه وكتير مهمه لازم تكون
غنيه كمان بالالياف بالسوائل بالبروتينات
والكربوهيدرات المعقده لحتى تعطينا طاقه
اطول فتره الصيام
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات